[Music]
and leave me alone oh stop leave me
alone I'm gonna buy it
supreme pie thank you sure supreme
supreme
yeah it's Mike Tyson he goes supreme I
lost my Mike Tyson Christmas sweater you
lose everything beard I know I even lost
my guitar I think we have one of your
Brown towels - does it have a hole we
don't have any brown does it have a hole
and you still want it it's the only one
that doesn't match all of our other
towels that was yours it's a tan brown
that's my professional mermaids say the
worst part of their job is the creepy
pervert what's the mervy professional
mermaid all the one that's that's swim
around and like the sea aquarium things
so wait dudes do this - and then bourbon
oh yeah I think it's the man roommates
and then it's the perfect chicks that
are like staring at his dog Oh what dog
he has a fin yeah here is it no no like
the the Murdoch the Murdoch it's a guy
you know the guy who verdicts so that
they have the fish bottom right from the
fish bottom if you look at where the
pelvic region is does usually a big
bulge there what do they call me mer man
its mermen yammer man no rooms or bird
Butler's if you're a merman and you're
talking another man it's like about
mermaids are you like yo dude are you a
boob man or a boob man a tail man or a
tail man right man is it fitting yeah I
rather have I think its tail fin I
rather have the opposite mermaid where
half of it is fish and the other one is
legs and ass also you go oh that's good
yeah
big fish head and then legs mast yep but
you can't even look at her in her eyes
cuz they're all nice how are you gonna
fly don't even look at girls in the eyes
when I [ __ ] anyway
turn around [ __ ] I want to see the back
of your [ __ ] eyes [ __ ]
as it should be a cutter resume of that
scary movie one where he's [ __ ] the
ghost but he makes her put up coz
they're like hot cuz like he was like
staring at her titties everything but
then she'd take off the bag she's like
oh just nothing well because if you get
actual mermaid you're putting your dick
inside of a fish that's nice I thought
you take him on land when they have
ladies and you [ __ ] them and then you
bring them back in the water but that's
only the Little Mermaid that's a Disney
time what splash with the movie Tom
Hanks oh that's the one we're watching
my in and out of like we were watching a
little bit and then we're like going
over here looking over there I'm eating
multiple times you've been to the market
imagine getting one of those Salmons or
tunas and [ __ ] the [ __ ] out of it
Gail's hurt yeah I do that those Salmons
had titties intestinal still that's
gross not a titty guy you lost him or
what if she just cities over a smart I
still like titties but if I had to
choose between which kind of mermaid
I'm just saying one is very practical
and the other one is not yeah but you
got oh god dude which one is which I
think I would take the upper body and
just we would just say just have to suck
dick myself oh that's time you get city
fun but that's not fair you could
probably find a fish [ __ ] in the back
somewhere what is a fish [ __ ] have I
seen a fish pushing that's probably a
fish [ __ ] between the fins somewhere
yeah give me that fish bush that's
another that's another shirt I'm not
[ __ ] a tilapia this professional
remained she her name is Stephanie she's
32 years old she performs as a mermaid
called Reina where she performed as a
remedy called Stephanie into the home I
know [ __ ] difference yeah yeah so
she's saying that she like the worst
part in San Diago no in Nova Scotia oh
that's cold water but mm-hmm
so she's saying like the worst part of
her job is the river it's okay what's a
murderer
so it's a pervert that just like parties
are like fish
ladies marine guys with like a nurse
fetish or made fetish or whatever so
they seek this out yeah so like they're
hot go I like the one they'll hold their
breath like that I don't like the
mermaid shows and have the scuba [ __ ]
it's like [ __ ] you ain't no
mermaid [ __ ] bubbles coming out so
and there's a [ __ ] cable around I've
seen [ __ ] lazy ass mermaids with the
scuba thing I seen him with a little
small holy thing that's you know you
know they're human though right no but
then he wants the fish are you sure I
want I want in the final part I want him
a free dive like that and hold your
breath like four minutes out of go back
to that picture the biggest talent here
the hair exactly yeah it's like how the
[ __ ] is it not all over the place and
maybe she was moving upwards as they
took the picture she probably has like a
apparatus here to hold it down yeah cuz
that hair should be like [ __ ] all
over the place like she got electrocuted
oh maybe it's really heavy it's like a
LED hair it's pushing her down that's
good I could still tell she's holding
her breath though she's like yeah right
see she's not a lazy mermaid that's
tight yeah so here's the more photos of
bringing a nice dose that is dope dope
I'll tell you something those pictures
don't make me horny though so I don't
know what kind of things these guys are
thinking about mermaids don't do [ __ ]
for me a that area was pretty hot yeah
as I can as a kid I play really hard
from him bill was the hottest one DOMA
she is the hottest one but I'm saying
Ariel as a mermaid Ariel cuz her waist
is all tiny she stick at the bottom she
got a nice cleavage yeah a cool here's
something huh why'd you class that last
word up there god I don't know she gots
a big ol titties something you got stuck
you're like she got some no cuz I was
trying to picture her and doesn't know
what else is chef Gail's gonna say all
her red ass hair and I'm like all these
they don't give a [ __ ] about like her
songs I gotta say cuz maybe it's like
winger maybe it's like how people are
born were like when you watch too much
of it you need more sicker and sicker
[ __ ] cuz like I think I start over the
Ariel but then I got to the point where
like I'm watching Lion King and [ __ ]
the way now is looking at I like nah
namitha sexy dollars fine I was like oh
god damn the way she [ __ ] landed on
him and looked him in the eyes I was
like that you can't beat a cat you can't
well she was [ __ ] him in that scene
yeah I think so which is interesting
it's a different level you can't take it
did yeah he had to if you're gonna be
king dude you got to do this first she
wasn't a version that's true she felt
like [ __ ] train on her ass
so back to the murder it's here so she
said that there's people that asked her
they could hump her belly and then I
don't get that what kind of question is
that
so they want to [ __ ] her bellybutton
that's definitely a [ __ ] virgin
question I think your belly no is it
cool if I hump your belly yeah another
one says you're delicious even without
any tartar sauce that's a great line
these are all virgins Oh 100% nothing
like I love to watch you swim that's
from a five-year-old I loved watching
well hold on because if you said it like
that it's pretty adorable yes this is
like a three out of ten mermaid like
pretend like she's getting hit on no let
me tell you what's of India a lemur make
me a lemur big there are ten but only a
five she had a stalker once where she
needed to get police involved because so
the stalker started following her after
she got her first front page in a local
newspaper story and then this dude
starts showing up at her work and that's
Troy wait this is a stalker silver with
the dorsal fin look it's about in the
back yeah he's he's a guy like Anil
reporting a dolphin issue yeah so then
she said that he would try to add her
friends on Facebook and then he even
chased her at one point dolphin cached
away she she can't she hot gas oven and
another time there was this promotional
photo shoot at a beach where there was
this man that kept insisting that they
must be filming a porno and asked if
mermaids were a fetish and then he kept
saying you're [ __ ] shooting porn here
there was another time where it was a
family-oriented event full of children
where this man waited in the lineup of
kids who were getting photos with her
just to heckle her about taking off
their tops or like if she gets that
telling them over and over again that
real mermaids don't worry I picture her
stalker to like [ __ ] be like this in
front of her house trying to like she
loves her job she does just like dealing
with these creeps that's [ __ ] weird
and then like there's like older female
magicians have to go through that - sure
I'm female have to go through all of it
because there's like a fetish for
everything literally everything
magicians assistants must get all kinds
of stuff can you make this dick
disappear yeah and so she's saying that
there's like a network of like all the
professional mermaids and so as soon as
one creep starts coming up and like
giving one of them report to each other
they all yeah they report to each other
and they just all immediately block a
Yelp for [ __ ] mermaid fans
I think the crappy thing is like a girl
can't say to a guy like how would you
like it if that happened to you he would
[ __ ] love it that's the sad part like
we can't relate to that fundamental
different I know we're like so thirsty
for attention [ __ ] losers all of us
we want to be sexually harassed because
that's like free yeah so how would you
like to be objectified it'll be great no
it'd be great for once yes that's why we
pay for it but that's how low guys are
derp like [ __ ] man I need ya can you
just like rub your ass on my face I'll
pay you $5 ya [ __ ] strip show right
it's like can you put your private parts
and just show me them and [ __ ] rub it
on my face you have it then I'm all
about the deal to where I'm like I'm
like she's like well it's 20s song or
whatever so then I'm in there and it's
like one song happened and if I hear the
[ __ ] beginning of a note for the
second song I'm like you don't I mean
I'm up I'm up and out I'm not paying
back
pant for two songs even like even if it
starts to bleed over I'll [ __ ] pick
her up and throw her off wait for the
two-for-one deal cuz he doesn't want to
pay extra I'm not paying extra we had a
deal for one song and you're trying to
you're trying to get me into it by the
end and I'm like no no no you're like
I'm done yep yep
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]